and the Democrats better hope that they
come up with some literally the only
chance I think that the Republican party
has is if he goes to prison it's not
even if he's convicted he got convicted
of a sexual assaulting that girl came
right on TV like she was 60. he said his
heels oh they're in a closet I own the
Plaza Hotel next door yeah I could have
smashed it in a room he almost was like
me he was like she brought me in the
room she pushed me up against the
dressing room he said a little bar I
loved it was like we went into this
closet which are all locked she forgot
that but I guess this one wasn't locked
like he was bringing out these like
little bits of information to prove that
it was absolute [__] he starts
talking about her pets she has a cat
named vagina I don't know what you want
to do with that but a cat named vagina
I've had a woman yeah what kind of woman
like a man in a closet but a cat named
vagina I just met this woman yeah